[Music]
yo
okay no one saw that failed live stream
right
yeah good great
what the hell is ace 24 hours
get out of here let's get out hold up
don't want to dox myself
oh we're playing resident evil
one second
[Music]
okay is that good we're good we're gucci
chad is here
what up [ __ ]
my friend philip is watching but he's
not a member so he can't type
sell it pay me
probably not going to see it anyway all
right
here we go continuing episode 4.
i forgot as always what the hell we were
doing
oh okay i'm an idiot
apparently red doesn't mean the house is
locked
obviously since i'm in the [ __ ] house
it means i haven't found all the loot in
there that's what that means
so we gotta find more loot let's
scavenge these romanian houses there it
is
found it i'm the best
that's it see that was blue why did
why does these things that are so normal
and so obvious
take me so long welcome to the mind of
an idiot
okay well we've done that now
uh i forgot what we were supposed to do
we need that
water wheel weapon
yeah all right well let's get it
it's gonna be mine peop i got so many
people also being annoyed with me trying
to navigate the map
the map make no sense you think you can
walk here but you can't
tell my buddy huh
that my fault then
uh i'm stuck again god damn it hold up i
got this
we got a shortcut no problem
we we got the gravestone didn't we yeah
we did
why are people saying gravestone then
and this is another
[ __ ] dead end this map make those the
map make no sense
the map makes no sense the map makes no
sense
it tells me i can go here but i can't
explain your sound
so to go here i have to go
a whole bing bong around
fine i will
oh i almost missed you
give me that perfect name
there it is
wait a minute we can go through here
not yet that's probably one of the later
ones
okay let's cut through the church i'm
getting the water weapon
it's mine and no one can stop me
it's just a bit of a walk
yeah is there no minimap
i guess not
okay where's the
oh we gotta go to the chicken it's down
here
i don't know if there's a mini man that
would make
things easier all right here we are
chickens
oh my gosh is it another den in oh no
oh
how help me help
help me i'm so dumb help me how do i
help me please
fine you know what i don't need a map
maps are for idiots who can't navigate
by looking at nature
uh the wind is blowing from the east so
that means
the way to go is over the
and romanians you go down here
yep oh yeah it all makes sense now
i've walked here a billion times what is
happening
okay okay okay okay i got i got it i got
it
oh look guys we're back where we started
oh okay yeah yeah oh yeah of course
of course you have to go here
uh then you have to go here look at the
goat's head
say hello three times i have to go here
and you have to go where was the tractor
bit
i'm actually so [ __ ] lost
that's a map change
well we loaded all this
okay we can't go there but we can
go there either
yeah we this is the blue gate there was
a shortcut
but where oh we're back here guys
this is the shortcut
i am so confused oh here oh my gosh
look here's why i always get confused
because that's a road but it doesn't
show up on the map
here we go okay
whoever made the map in this game [ __ ]
you hope you turn into a zombie
and that's a dead end
okay we're on the right track
so there's meister's collection in that
house in this house
how we get in though
i wanna get inside you
there we go oh
yes finally there's also a goat here
that i missed that was like
in plain sight i watched through the
other time here we go
to whom and make concern due to
luthier's long absence i'm keeping hold
of the house key please find me if you
need it
joseph simmons yeah we've been here we
have the house key now
yes let's go give me oh look it's a pot
for the 500th time
oh look guys there's a sink oh [ __ ]
there was something in the sink first
time
it's finally worth looking at all these
things happy birthday
damn romanians know how to draw i don't
know
that's awesome
okay
okay there has to be something good in
here
is it is it his daughter's birthday
i'll never forget her fifth birthday
never forget that one
uh 27 0 9
17.
old is she
is that it okay
let's try it
yes
was it nine
i am a genius
hey hey hey oh
whoa rifle we don't even have a rifle
excuse me where does this go
oh yes
upgraded baby let's go oh
it looks badass now i like it
cool so we got my source collection i
want the water
i want the water weapon we're going for
that next
the water weapon will be mine and we
loaded these
oh we missed some loot in there gotta
get it
have to get it all obviously otherwise
what's the point
what i miss
okay i i admire his collection of tools
i really do
what the [ __ ] did i make
the fridge yeah the house is still red
turn upstairs no
hello i don't think we need every house
to be fully looted right
yeah look up would make sense there's a
ladder
in the ceiling kind of sauce
on the shelves
uh i honestly don't know
in the guitar oh
you liar
you lie
no i can't destroy them what about these
indestructible
no no
look over the ceiling why if you don't
know don't speak
okay okay maybe we should ditch this i
don't think it's worth it
we did find the pot again
all right yeah
oh oh my [ __ ] god where did that come
from
did i drop from the guitar when i hit it
huh okay thanks for nothing chad
as always okay now it's blue nice
okay nice that's blue
okay we're done here we're done here
gamers
and then we have this area but that just
leaves us back here
and it doesn't look like we can enter
here yet so we'll have to wait for the
water gun
although i remember it being a goat here
that was like in pla honestly it was in
plain sight and i don't know how i
didn't see it
where was that
it was outside could have been here
the game is stuttering let me restart my
program there
it's not stuttering for me
is that better
uh i'll find it at some point
oh we haven't found all in this one
check out the maiden's quarters
here we go oh great lincoln license
the fabled monster wolves of old may
they come to eat our flesh
may they come to terrace apart nice
don't care at all
why is she so poor come on lady
you have something
[ __ ] up her window no reason it looks
like someone's sleeping there
here we go yes
yes i knew that old lady was up to
something
still red yeah
[Applause]
adi is she hiding
[ __ ] your plates lady
you got apples
hmm
still sound like the game is stuttering
okay i'll restart my playstation then
uh maybe it's outside
all right there's no reason to be super
anal about finding everything
uh we can't go here
but why
let's go back i'll do a save and we'll
i'll restart my playstation
hey man how you doing
damn that's worth a lot
pure gold i wonder if any of these
crystals can fit in
[Music]
give me something no none of these fit
all right save say
it seems fine so no restart okay good
don't really want to do that
i want to go fishing
the [ __ ] are these sounds is making more
important than anything
anything my friend
i don't think we need anything i'll save
my money for now
let me know if you find anything else of
value oh yeah someone told me i can put
something here
okay
[Music]
what the hell it happens
leg you want a leg
people are trolling about the audio
that's hilarious
uh
oh my gosh i miss so much this breaks my
heart
oh god oh god maybe we can
go here can we go here is this another
part of town
wait hold up is this unlocked
please come on
yes that water gun will be mine
oh i'm so ready dude
ow whoa
ethan's having a bad time man
[Applause]
okay i guess i'll run uh here i go
uh bang bang bang go away shame on you
yeah how dare you
how am i alive after that
the wounds are severe i won't last much
longer i can hear it shuffling about
outside
it's shuffling it barely flinched when i
shot it
i feel like it's toying with me daddy's
okay oh herbs
nice so uh i guess people have been
pointing out how in the game before
resident evil 7
ethan got some super what is that a
horse oh horsey no
ethan got some super powers that made
him heal quicker and that's why
but still i mean come on but still
all right let me investigate the audio
clipping i don't understand what the
deal is
it is clipping yeah what the [ __ ] why is
it doing there
hmm
i wonder why maybe let me try this
i'll try and avoid restarting if i don't
have to
okay let's try this
there's absolutely no stutter for me
let's try this
is that better
hmm
yeah it's good now isn't there
hey here i am sorry about that
it was my obs
okay oh we got chickens coming up [ __ ]
yeah let's murder them
sorry chickens uh a trap it's a trap go
in the hole
they lure you in like a chicken
okay we can go here
i hear the chickens
don't worry chickens i'm coming
don't be scared if chickens can survive
a werewolf
so can i
there's a [ __ ] pot again
oh should i barricade myself
just to be safe
you're right mate this is gonna hang
around there
i'm sure he can't hurt me what is he
gonna do eat me alive
how you doing [ __ ] how are you
what are you gonna do what are you
getting there oh yeah
yeah he can't reach me from here
idiot
oh i think he can reach me from here
that's fine
oh his head gets stuck
he's cliffing through the wall dude
no leave leave
he wants me so bad
hell yeah um
he'll get tired eventually i'm sure
he'll get higher
i'll just have a nap bro you keep doing
your thing just try not to make too much
noise
don't worry chickens i'm coming to
rescue you
am i supposed to shoot him i don't think
he takes damage
can i knife him that's a good question
oh i can't
yes die [ __ ]
can you kill him
i have a feeling you can't kill it
i'll see you guys in three hours when
he's dead
oh he clicked out a little bit there we
go
you hear the slicing sound yeah i'm
definitely hitting him
he's right oh he's back he's back
there we go he fixed himself
why is this happening
i'm so confused
well hopefully we'll do some damage you
know
okay this is boring hold up all right
all right we got this
is he dead
oh my god he's still going
i give up we probably need like silver
bullish or something
stupid [ __ ]
he's still going he's still [ __ ]
going
hey bro i'm right here
oh no he gave up
[Applause]
hey hey hey
yeah i think i have i'm supposed to
sneak out right
okay let's say that again the music
stopped so
we're all we're all good it's all good
that's just
it takes five shots with a grenade
launcher so you can kill him
oh so oh i wish he told me that two
seconds ago
okay let's lure him up again
where do you go
i do have landmines
i could use that
where is he now
uh
oh gosh there's zombies in here
uh okay
hey how you doing
all right there's another one in here
uh anyway
hey don't shoot don't shoot sweetie
why am i crouching he can't hit me
because i'm crouching
crouch gang all right let's go up sir
sure you can't reach me upstairs oh
we're back here
this is where we uh held off from all
the evil people
okay we looted everything here we gotta
get to the chickens fellas
i assume we can't go here
uh let's scouch scout i mean
hello it's way over there
where do we want to go oh yeah the
treasure okay let's go straight then
but no i haven't gotten the chickens yet
i need those chickens maybe we can
distract them with the radio
no honestly i'm a bit lost
run run chickens i'm coming
chickens i'm coming a beach
yeah all right let's hold up as long as
possible
what the hell he just ran away
oh i scared him off little chicken all
right how the [ __ ] do i get to the
chickens
chickens
seriously the map the [ __ ] map
ah here he comes
where is he
look the map clearly says you can go
right here
hey there's a ladder there
if i need to get on the roof
homie i'm confused
i just want to get to the chickens don't
worry i'm coming that's boarded off
is that a door there there's a cog wheel
that's kind of suss
hey is there a hole in the ground i
missed
all right well ah for [ __ ] sake
let's do this hey mr werewolf
you can't scare me what's he doing over
[Applause]
there
well let's just equip it just want this
loot
man maybe this
[ __ ] what can i use here
hmm we probably need to find something
uh okay we'll get the chickens
later fine
okay hold up hey mr werewolf
got a pancake got a pancake for you
oh no hey hey
you're supposed to come here
i missed there you go come here
he died but werewolf i had a present
oh what a sinker rooney
he was like a father to me
i'm so sad where was my best friend look
this is where he grew up
so small so precious
he was so close to dying
uh yeah we'll do the dollhouse thing
later okay one thing at a time gamers
well this changes things let's check
down here
i will find you chickens i will find you
the reservoir oh nice and gooey
i like it
what's all this then slimy substance
looks breakable
i guess we need some other item maybe a
flamethrower
yeah who the [ __ ] said five grenade
shots bro i hit him with one knife
and a pancake
okay
what are we cooking snow nice
uh
hold up where the [ __ ] are we
i want to go there and
here but i need an item that we haven't
found yet
i think it was we haven't checked here
have we
yeah no no we haven't here we go
oh yes
oh very good
there it is okay can i automatically
sort
because this is a mess
uh god damn it i don't want to do this
okay
uh the me here
how much that's the
oh my god
how much does a grenade launcher take
a weird minigame
of me pressing the wrong buttons over
and over here we go
there you are i didn't see you there
buddy
boom yes
what all right
that's all right man
you go there thank you
thank you grenade launcher
i guess that's what you were supposed to
kill it with
[Laughter]
i love that oh we got a luck pick nice
this is is this uh red it's still red
strange
maybe outside
that's gotta be outside
can we unlock this now please
[ __ ] your wheel
why is it red huh hey am i missing
rub my back
oh i never picked it up for [ __ ] sake
okay
nice sorry about that
i guess we can shoot the goo now
but i want the chickens
chickens
what kind of key do we put here
what is it it looks like a cog wheel
from the
from the windmill
where's all this goo man
hmm all right let's deal with the goo
people say you can knife it but i don't
see anything happening
oh whoa whoa whoa
when in doubt do it out
okay just this area
okay
well okay we'll find something for the
chickens in there
for sure nice
pigs i will save you hey pigs
it's locked on the other side can you
open
please
well i guess i have another way
yes climb
is there going to be another werewolf
what up pigs all right watch this pigs
360. 360 off the cliff
and saving the pig's life i'm saving
your life i'm saving your life
you're gonna live you're gonna lie on
the fjords
don't run you make the suffering more
slice that ace yeah baby don't attack
back away you [ __ ] ass
i'm trying to save your life over it do
not hit me you're not him
stop don't run from the inevitable
yes hey hey hey don't fight back don't
fight that
give me that ass boy give me that ass
watch me die from a pig and not the
werewolf
how much health do you have jesus
there we go saved him he's saved
oh another puzzle what are we dropping
here
uh the photo of a strange bird for sure
what
okay so we have found two of these
but nothing to put inside
let's check it out oh
say you say
just stick my hand in there
rare animal oh
we got we're going hunting boys my
health is actually really low
i'm sure it's fine what are you gonna do
kill me
where's he hanging around huh where is
he
uh some blue curtain thing mountains in
the back
uh-huh looks like he's wait there was a
caption on it i didn't see that
a photo of a beast as white as know
where was it taken i think we already
killed that to be honest
i'm pretty sure we did
yeah i think we i mean save that i think
we already saved that
where the [ __ ] are we going
yeah we definitely already got the white
pig they made a whole big
fusser about it
it's dead i mean saved
i will save all the animals all of them
well this is creepy
barrels
nice very nice
oven here no it's so dark i can't see
check this out more people trash
everywhere huh
okay let's check that out in a second
nothing literally nothing
some sound coming from here oh it's a
squeeze through that means something's
gonna happen
jumpscare in one no
she's watching pewdiepie worry she won't
get distracted
[Music]
[Applause]
i guess she's not a fan what the [ __ ]
hey how are you doing you sub
or what i'll just be taking this wait
what what
what are you doing with mother's special
child she's not
have something herself say what do you
mean
mother's special child father what's
her baby back don't screw with me wait
wait please
please if you take it let me
[Music]
don't come near me
oh fine you can have it
you're the slime guy
[ __ ] does he know i can literally just
knife them
freak is here where are they
this is my character ah more go now
oh more goo stop it not to go
it's mine i saw it first oh let's go
this way then
how do i get out of here i mean it looks
like i just did [ __ ]
we got a plate of lemon
for the sour [ __ ]
looks pretty
mother miranda's discord mod
[Laughter]
uh leave the boat key and the shack in
the mine
is dead so no more fishing for a while
damn it i want to go fishing
i mean we all know his death with no
accident was eaten by giant fish
boat and all there's a giant fish
hell yeah we're gonna kill it
it's gonna die isn't that right boot you
god damn right
so we need the boat key right yeah okay
so we gotta go back in
hans aons
oh barrel you can a breakable barrel
nice
and i can't seem to cross
why is that
okay back to the mine back to the mine
okay
oh thank you
oh there's a bunch of fish there
oh they actually didn't mean to go i
don't think i can pick them up
okay it's funny they use these yellow
things as a hint to where to go it's
kind of cool
some force could break it there you go
i did it so smart
yeah look yellow again
maybe i should just quick behind the
[ __ ] knife
oh no okay
big fight coming up probably crotch gang
okay okay definitely time to make use of
these
uh yeah
anyone wants a snack
crouch gang
ah you know what that's not a good one
all right
[Music]
we good sorry about that bro
ah come on don't move stop strafing
told you to stop
maybe that was a bit of a waste there's
only two then
oh [ __ ] those guys are tough
hey we got the vote key
uh well he they drop a lot of loot those
i definitely want to kill him
how many one hey how you doing
i did not expect that all right hold up
hold up
hold up present present present
present present don't walk right now
don't walk right now
walk on the thing bruh can i not heal
him out of him
oh
there you go
and another one
[Applause]
okay nice
are we done gotta get the loot you know
oh god so many
uh one at a time lady thank you
[ __ ] i just gotta reload bro
what's wrong with you
they drop a lot
okay yeah i think we got everything
oh thank you
i love that he jumped through the window
that was great
didn't expect that dude there's so much
fish here and a boot
okay so which way now this way
ah something in the water
is that the crank no
did we get a crank
no
i like how he said he blocked us off but
literally like we can
can we break through this
we can just do that
i know i know this is a dead end
i just want to see if you could maybe go
through
oh never mind
all right time to go fishing at last
probably
oh look at that
nice
it was worth the extra trip after all
nice doing good we killed blob
we killed pigs saved pigs
we killed what oh [ __ ] i didn't see them
oh wait they don't even see me yet all
right
but i thought they were one shot i've
been tricked in bamboozle
i don't like this
hold on let me relay
there you go
do not don't don't
thank you
not wasting shotgun ammo on these fools
hey boot time to go fishing
oh yeah let's go
hold up hold up hold up there was
something behind there
oh god the map we gotta turn around
yeah i ain't going there [ __ ] that
can i go here please say yes
nope the chest is right there i want it
why should we break the boat
whoa what
all right
what was that i don't know we're
following it apparently
[Music]
yeah this is definitely not her boat's
here but i like it
makes it less annoying what i parked it
perfectly
oh no other side thanks game
[Laughter]
all right fishes can't attack me on land
i'm completely saved
can i go through this
what the hell this is the weirdest thing
you've seen today or something
what the [ __ ] are they doing here
kill off from him
stay the [ __ ] down ethan
i gotta say i'm surprised you made it
this far are you really
after all i've done something happened
to you now sir chris
why not you killed mia now do me and
finish the job
hey cat i'm getting some serious motion
readings out here
we should move on
what kind of readings what's moving
unknown but my guess is we've been here
too long and miranda knows it hey
hey did you say miranda how are you
involved leave it alone ethan you are
out of your depth
what about the sample analysis it's
definitely related to the mold
there were fish no
you stay out of our business
we can fishing out we're in the water
oh it's you stay
here's a fish your egg sits on the water
your dog i don't have time for this
[Music]
don't be cruel
[Applause]
he is a discord mod
twitch top donor right here
[Music]
whoa okay all right i'll go
ow stop me
i'll be
whoa yeah i'm a land [ __ ]
we're gonna do right
nothing what am i supposed to do i don't
know
oh this way which means we will have to
check this out first
gatehouse you see the exits underwater
yes
if i can drain the water
ah [ __ ] there's no power no
someone sleeping in there
uh uh-huh uh-huh okay so
uh-huh that my audio just cut off
glitch
hello who's sleeping
hello i know you're oh it's you
what the [ __ ] are you doing then feel
free to peruse
i will thank you ah
damn it we need the [ __ ] fish i have
so much meat
everything is fish that fish do
oh i'm so mad i need the fish
give me the fish now shut up
god damn welcome ethan
i'm skilled at all sorts of weapons
modifications and we'll do them for a
small fee
maybe reload speed is worth it because i
was struggling
a little bit
[Music]
whoa 20 000 for killing that damn
a dirty teddy bear
should i sell all this stuff
i won't sell the bear but i will sell
where did you get your hands on such a
thing i don't know i'm way too rich
honestly
pay me no mind
i need sniper ammo
yes i can see why you have a wonderful
adventure
i thought i bought so i can craft it's
like grandma
there we go okay
i'll keep the bear for now you never
know
toilet gotta check it
i got an achievement for that excellent
uh i'm really hungry can i just
five-minute break and have a snack it's
alright
i'll probably be less honestly i'll hold
him back
so
so
so
okay i'll just eat my snack but you
don't get to watch haha
you fool
just pretend i'm eating like a
microphone or something
oh we're back by the chickens
windmill two checker
atlanta
yes yes
nope
can't run for me chickens
what oh hell yeah
thank him
windmill too windmill's so good they
made a second one
there you are
no no no no i don't want to do this
seriously
oh
how would i say there's no safe station
there you go
all right i'm done thanks for waiting
gamer
okay let's continue
it doesn't show up on the map
well maybe we can trade the chickens now
i don't remember how many i needed but
oh good i was just thinking of ways to
pass the time
[ __ ] fish [ __ ] you fish
oh my gosh we can make this
everything else needs fish
don't let up yet we've gathered all the
ingredients
now
apologies for the wait
hell to think such a dish could be had
in this
winterbound frontier
one more meat and one more fish and we
have our chorba de porque
oh my god it was right there
okay
i've been wanting fish so bad in this
[Applause]
game
it's some [ __ ]
ah here we are no
where the [ __ ] is it
windmill two suck
all right here we go fish is going to
attack me
fish get him
come on fish come on fish
come on fish
what
no it's ammo
oh brick
but where fish everywhere
and nowhere
oh big not looking
i am looking i am
oh maybe we can go here
i feel like that's a bad idea
we're fine
i don't even see it
wait i thought for sure i cleared a path
what the [ __ ] did i do then look what a
cute little chimney
i haven't even fished
hold up but i miss
can i run here
it's a time thing i have to do
why don't i see it
um
i gotta push it over but what
shoot it
that's so dumb why did you tell me to do
that
let's try this
dead look it doesn't even attack me
are there yellow planks somewhere
has to be yellow somewhere
[Music]
where
maybe i have to lure the fish
oh there we go
that was tricky to see we got it
and fish went away hooray
this is gone forever now we beat the
game
now then what's all this thing
hey we made a thing
okay i love how useless the fish is
hey i could stinks
i just get over yourself ethan you've
seen worse
you seem far worse at this point
all right all right all right
magnum ammo i don't even have the magnum
yet what the [ __ ]
it's not gonna hold it's not gonna hold
all that for magnum ammo
okay so it's blue orange is that a fish
no blue orange white
i assume white is over there
wait hold up how do i get back up
oh let's see
was there white over there
oh here's what okay
so i probably have to pull a white last
hold up i didn't forgot about the orange
i should do it run
all right
this [ __ ] guy
oh [ __ ] mama
i actually got hit
oh we're dying
all up now
you are the best
all right we gotta watch out for this
one i guess
what
am i supposed to run back
yeah i'm supposed to run back there okay
nice
oh my gosh
hey help
and now we can go nice
hey stop bait zero dash there we go that
did not count because he's a simple
am i gonna kill it or what [ __ ] you
plate
ah at last
caught myself a big one whoa
how the hell did we lift that up
[Music]
how do i get there's another question
windmill too oh i just jumped down
as soon as i've looked for luke
why is this taking forever
i just gotta check for a little bro
oh
can you kill the fish
he dropped loot i want his luke
i gotta get that
the crank the crank is eyes
you can't climb up like this
what do i do then um oh we gotta use the
crank maybe
that's not where i wanted to go maybe
that did something
there we go
stop stop it you're super annoying
oh
yes time to kill fish
should we crank this this cranky boy
is cranky
okay yes
open this loose game don't mind if i
do open the sluice gate
hey man i won't open the sluice gate
you mine
welcome ethan thank you
i have not caught any fish unfortunately
but
please do take a look at my new stock
um
bits and bobs i see
[ __ ] you teddy bear you're done
all right what should we get
might as well get the shotgun recoil
sure yes i can see why you'd be
interested in that
and the rate of fire
[Music]
all right touch it
it's the wrong one it's for the other
shotgun
now how much do i spend on that yes yes
[Music]
one moment please
food is life indeed thank you for your
patronage
all right oh puzzle
uh-huh this is
what how do i does it depend on which
way you're looking at it maybe
so let's say this is white and this is
white
it's blue and black has to be here
can that turn black oh black is the only
one that can turn so black is there okay
there we go uh-huh and blue
oh wait i saw it wrong [ __ ] uh
no oh my god it's difficult to look at
it this way
this is right that's supposed to be blue
and it's supposed to be white
and it's supposed to be blue
orange blue
no you're blue
you're orange
and then your orange your y
and your orange
white
nice
got it got it
hell yeah you're dead he's dead now i
did it
you see that i killed the fish
looking blob what's he doing here
that's chilling looking at bricks
i respect that
move the windmills with the crank just
oh i should have streamed a read this
before
excellent
ah [ __ ] it's fine
honestly i got a way to deal with these
guys
i'm gonna kill you i'm gonna get you i'm
gonna get you by
where he go
vicious we can get vicious now
there must be
please ah
dang it hey i'll take some luke
october 1st a sunny day mother miranda
brought me five peoples
from the village the peoples
just like i asked they did i made them
sleep with some liquid and then i put
caddo in their tummies i am looking
forward to the caddo
to grow in their tummies
october 2 a cloudy day four of the
people from the village
are dead this morning one first is
almost
a lichen i sent it to my lab on the
mountain
i failed again mother one strong vessel
but i cannot get any
i will need more people from the village
uh-huh okay very good
oh yes i want this
very long and strong
okay
down we go what's all this thing
follow the cable oh here we go
[Applause]
nice
hello this is where we find
let me just reload bruh
hey
oh [ __ ]
shoot him shoot him shoot him that was
the time to shoot
oh don't mind if i knew
[ __ ] thought i would get more out of
that
oh
am i dying
oh i gotta get undercover i went too far
[ __ ]
there was no cover there
all right let's do this all again but
better
[Music]
there was no cover i went too far ahead
i guess
we're good
ah that's cool
[Music]
show yourself
why is
okay so when he says watch this i
probably shouldn't hang around and
actually watch it
okay let's cover here
no you're right
okay
come on show me your titty thing
oh
what
nice he's trying he's trying i'll give
him there
okay we need cover now
we can use one
he's kind of cute
jump jump jump i got a sniper now
nope
[Music]
what was that
i'm gonna die i'm gonna die
i hate this one
come on
all right all right okay okay we have
pancakes let's use them
okay i'm right here
please just come
what
there we go
did it didn't feel good but i got him
and death as he was in life disgusting
nice one-liner bro
i didn't understand his moveset at all
but he dead
very dead
all right let's get the remains
and let's get the book out of here
oh these are so i hate these they have
them everywhere on rocks in sweden and
they cut you open like knives dude
not a fan
they gave you minds they literally gave
you minds
okay
that rate of fire with a shotgun is so
awkward too it's like boom and then you
click and then it's like no
boom
all right where's exit though
there
i want my goddamn fishes
the exits up ahead thank you
cool need that
you barrel
hold up
this is his house mother miranda gave me
a roast jar no one likes me which
is why i thought they would leave me out
again but heisenberg said that we
that that was why we each get a rose the
ceremony can happen without us all there
mother didn't seem to care though mother
mother said rose is a vessel with a
vessel mother can get her real child
back
even though she has been dead for a very
long time but if mother does
then what will happen to me and
i'm not her real child would she abandon
me no
i don't want that ah
what is he snacking on some cheese nice
ah caddo
that a lesson to be learned never be the
same
who's that oh come on oh my [ __ ] just
met a while back nothing really matters
you're the last [ __ ] in my way aren't
you you've got
fights i'll give you that even but
what's the plan when you have all four
flasks
drink trying to get at baby drink i
could lend you a hand
not trying to get on my good side go
don't get cocky
i'd kill you if you weren't worth the
trouble
there's a stronghold not too far outside
the village
go there and get my flask do that
and you pass first head back to the
graveyard
self-centered prick
homies just chilling in a jar man
i like that i like that a lot
now we can leave
open
right we're still down here is that the
elevator what does that mean labyrinth
puzzle
we didn't get anything that we can
use for the puzzle i believe unless the
crank is the key
can i break it
let's get out of here
bye bye mr fish
it's been a place
okay
long way up huh i don't remember this
all right
oh my god at last the crank
apparently i forgot everything
i have the rocket launcher where the
[ __ ] are you guys on about
but we're not going here yet though hold
up
we ain't going here yet
oh it's getting daytime now that's cool
i've unlocked then are we locked in
what is that a hidden weapon
ah i want that
yeah the boat chest that's right
this way
thanks i want to go back to the altar
no no no i'm going
oh god is that the river
this way papa
oh he took it no way
that's kind of cool
it's not much else to definitely offer
in the [ __ ]
one moment please
yes we broke gang now
or ours this is lord moroz i suppose
it's what they call
the beauty of the grotesque
a good deal if i say so myself indeed
now we're gonna go here
and we're gonna put the grave slab if
y'all remember
ages ago
cool i like how the everything changes
when fire nation attacking
apparently i skipped the magnum i don't
know how i did that but
i think we're good
no this is the house this is where the
puzzle is we don't want the hustle
ah
no way
can i not cut through
why that's so lame
okay oh i can go through
here thank god
no we're just
here can we cut through here oh yes
okay we're good
[Music]
what the [ __ ] that's huge
pancake pancake
did he just walk through my pancake
hello you know why
i'll
i brought gift
i hit the tree i hit the [ __ ] tree
this is [ __ ] up dude does he not
follow me
oh god uh
so i have to find him on site like i
don't get it
oh
i actually thought he wouldn't follow me
what
i'm [ __ ] blind uh
hey [ __ ] who's the big
how are you still alive
what's all this thing
that's a tough guy
big man
yes at last we get this charlize
we got the charlize yeah
nice
we got the charlize i'm so happy we got
the charlize
can't wait to use my
charles
what the [ __ ] do i use a charlie's for
this some [ __ ]
as for the labyrinth puzzle no
no way
no way jose those were not there before
i'm sorry where's the libra that's the
save point
how
oh oh sun and moon ball
look at it girl look at you
wow oh strong
curve but we stronger
it's kind of satisfying
cool
heading back gamers
which way is it again doesn't matter
we're gonna get fish now i've decided
we're not doing anything until i get a
fish
fish now
even you look so pretty in the sunlight
what do we got we got this one we just
need one [ __ ] fish
and then the finest fish i'm skilled at
all sorts of weapons modifications and
oh we're rich we're out here we're very
rich
since we can sell it are we supposed to
use him or something
ah
i'm too rich dude what am i oh we can
upgrade
this simple modification can be done in
just a moment
leave this to me
delighted to
might as well have so much money
or we had so much money
okay all right let's think we have the
chickens
but the thing is i don't think we need
any chickens
you wish to make a purchase
look unless we get it no we already had
that
look fish fish
fish fish [ __ ]
let's get the chicken come again just
because i'm mad about it
all right this is where come on little
chickens come on now
at last at long last the chickens are
ours
two little chicken
and pewdiepie with a knife
come on come on come on come on what you
got what you got huh
you talk you think you're tough [ __ ]
oh no
no no did i get it did i get it did i
get it
oh i got it i got it okay
why is this open
savages
what is all this then
a mountain path
oh what is that that's a flag thing
pigeon blood ruby maybe fits a necklace
at last cool
we need one more that's kind of dope
i like that okay we're
definitely done here
it's fishing time i ain't going that way
[ __ ]
okay okay can we go back
all right guys tell me where i can fit
i can really zoom out a lot
hidden weapon
so hidden that's the magnum then that's
what we missed
i doubt we can go back
[Music]
yes they want you to replay the game
[Music]
[Music]
um
oh yeah there's a crank on the
drawbridge fish
yes our time has come at legs
yes
where are they oh there's a boat
guys guys there's a bloody boat we're
going fishing
i'm sorry where am i going
are we going where i think i'm going
upstream like a salmon
we are back here
[Music]
uh-huh no we went north
is this so we can backtrack now maybe
what the [ __ ]
i finished that item that was requested
please deliver to the house with the red
chimney we're back here
no way oh my god this is
nostalgic almost thinking about mama
all the doors alive
said the other way
but what's all this thing
well everyone's saying well
where was there well sorry
oh well you're right thank you
i thought i said well well well and
everyone kept going
[ __ ] out forgot the well
you're right my bad
oh wait that's not the crank
what a ladder oh
spooky
so scary
whoa what's
all this thing
what
ah is this a puzzle
got to push these around and stuff
that's the reaper
can't seem to interact with much though
clearly i gotta move something
maybe something here
oh i can climb up
that's it oh my [ __ ] god
amazing
here's the puzzle okay so
we want these to switch play
um
damn
these things don't mess about
huh
hello
why can i push this
what's the point of doing this so i can
climb it up
oh now i can push
yay could just walk
like that as well
i always think the puzzles are harder in
my head so i'm thinking of a bigger
picture
and then it's like oh no you literally
just push it and then
oh nice
at last it's complete
that better be worth a [ __ ] light
dude
[Music]
cool
i like the little small puzzle stuff
that you don't have to do it's just kind
of like
well it helps your game and it's fun to
make sure you explore everything but now
we have a long way to go back
okay so we got that we still have this
riverbank house structure
hello it's not letting me go through
anymore
what
why not what
what we were there a second ago
why would he be locked now no we went
here
sorry
everything looks the same i'm dumb
alright
there's something in there
we got plenty of loot in there we got to
lift that thing
somehow
oh we gotta really swing it
swing girl
up you go now on my head
there he goes it's gonna hit it
perfectly
ow
oh my god that actually worked holy [ __ ]
i did it i'm a genius
uh [ __ ] i was not ready for that
yeah better posture [ __ ]
[Applause]
ah
one extra for good luck you know are we
done here
[Applause]
whoa rich gang
sniper him no what's the point
i got an achievement for that
let's go that's so cool
sorry bro i actually didn't mean to at
all
i keep hitting it
you were my first text test subject can
i let this no way it reaches there
oh i get it i get it okay okay cool
cool hey hey got present for you bro
come here gummy
yeah yeah yeah burn burn burn let it
burn follow me bro follow me it's gonna
be awesome
yeah yeah yeah you want this you want it
no no no come here
please i'm defenseless i have no defense
ah thank you you're the best don't come
near me don't go near me don't conner me
disgusting hill
that's so cool
stefano
oh more magnum ammo yay hey
all right cool little bonus area i like
that
no bye bye
so what happens if we go up even further
can we
nope
okay someone named assassin
assist wrote a donation to tell me
there's two more fish locations when
you're back at the boat go all the way
downstream there's a rare fish
and another is back where you did the
two crest puzzle near the entrance
of castle jimmy scream
okay let's go downstream first thank you
very much
i hope this is correct
i'm gonna get that fish
give me that give me dick give me that
give me that fish
okay where are the [ __ ] fish
i'm getting angry
if i don't get a fish soon fish
[ __ ] you
this is how we fish in sweden
finest fish oh so fine
oh fish just a fan
yeah yay
finally finally
okay we got it
[ __ ] is there any other point of this
area
where's where's this heading
uh creepy as [ __ ] this is a short cut
through
whoa we've been
dna sequencing complete ninety nine
point nine five percent match to
dulves the deviation of 0.05
can be can presumably be attributed to
artificial changes by humans which means
this is
probably the source further
investigation into how the connections
managed to find and
extract the mold is needed right there's
a whole thing that the fungal colony is
spread out
under the entire village when you take
the bakery incident into account the
hosts of the
muta my seat are part of a network of
consciousness
if that network is linked to here then
we could assume this organism
here is data storage if that's the case
then
what data is miranda they are connected
the stories oh
flashbangs
is that for our shotgun
yes cool fully upgraded
whoa
jake says that scared me
yes
oh that was great
nice nice
what are they doing
i don't know
[Music]
she
[ __ ] startled me i was looking at
that
tree and i ran like
[Music]
oh
that was cool
i love how he does this
okay we are heading back to the village
and we're giving this man our fish
looking window shop away finest fish in
the land my dude
we can't make that we can't make that
but we can make
six fish that's so much fish what
oh no oh no what have i done
i need two more fish
ah
the next batch of fishes is north of the
graveyard where i got the slab
let's do that
oh there's a [ __ ] goat
that's awesome oh there's another one
what did he drop though no don't
i'm just gonna shoot it because i don't
wanna
i'm here for fish and you're blocking me
thank you a lot of meat but no
fish why does goats not drop fish
seriously
bash come to me
yes
it's useless to fight
only two i saw more
i saw more more
two did i pick it all up and i didn't
realize
oh there was one more
it's a really interesting way to level
up your
character by [ __ ] making
it making you do this kind of stuff it's
great though i like it
oh well i think we're nearing the end of
the game
um
considering all the stuff yes
so we have five fish we could make this
we could also make this why did i not
see this before
and we can also make this no we can't
make that let's
yeah let's do this
we've gathered all the ingredients nice
now
let's get cooking
[Music]
here it is
damage taken while guarding to think
such a difference greatly
winterbound frontier we've gathered
all the ingredients we have now
[Music]
here it is please join me
to think such a dish could be had in
this winterbound frontier
two more chicken and three more fish i
don't know if we're gonna actually get
that's all an
investment even uh
looks like the one in bakerhouse oh look
at that
50 000 for the next one something to
splurge on
damn we're rich again dude we keep going
from rich to
richer securing goods is more important
than anything
anything my friend delighted to
let's max out just because we're rich
nice save station
i gotta end that stream there thanks for
joining guys hope you enjoyed it i had a
lot of fun i love playing this game for
you guys and
i just appreciate you being here
honestly
have a great day and i'll see you
tomorrow bye bye
bye
[Music]
foreign